you
a rerecording mixer takes a multitude of
elements and sources some from the shoot
some added after its music Foley sound
effects and adds them all together and
tries to create some kind of cohesive
world which will sit with the project
that they're working on the stage I get
involved in the making of film is
generally right near the end of the film
after it's been edited after it's the
music's being composed probably after
the grade has happened and it generally
is the last process in in the in the
chain before the film or TV show is
released which means it's a very nice
process because you especially on a film
where you sit in a room with a large
screen and you can the director sees
their project for the first time on a
big screen with with the sound sound
incorrectly that's probably the first
time they've seen it in the in the
correct environment is a very pleasant
experience qualities needed to excel in
this field being able to read people's
minds the ability to look into the
future when events happen that are
unplanned but really I think the
understanding of a project through the
directors eyes and the ability to work
within the team understand is a team
project and you're part of a massive
people trying to deliver something
closest relationships I think I'll form
are on a on a mix will be with the in no
order of importance I think they all
equal will be director producer not so
much protection generally the director
and the supervising sound editor because
between the three of us or if I have a
co mix was well between the four of us
will that will be deciding and forming a
unit that will guide the soundtrack in a
certain direction some more TV show
sometimes the producer is the is the
leading creative force so Jenny who if
its bid between the director and the
producer the leading creative force the
day-to-day routine is completely
dependent on the project actually that's
part of the mind reading process I don't
really have a set approach to the job
technically I have a set approach to the
job but but artistically it's completely
led by the project and the personnel
in the room and I don't think anybody
knows how a group of four or five people
will react together in the room and
that's the skill where you get in the
room and you work together as a team and
then you work out your strengths and
weaknesses and move the project forward
my technical approach or a job is fairly
regimented generally it starts with a
kind of a mixing process where myself
and the supervising sounded has probably
left on our own for a bit just to do the
technical mixing the kind of cleaning up
of noisy recordings and and panning
moving stuff around the screen adding
reverberation two spaces to establish
space a director and editor will
probably evolved occasion in that
process pop in now and again to make
sure in the going in the right direction
in the right and ten then we'll move on
to a process called final mix where
everyone will sit in the room hopefully
together and all the technical work has
been done at that point so hopefully the
final mix is a creative process where
big bold brushstrokes and sound can be
performed and I mean for an example in
something not normal i mix in thin red
line there's a scene where they're in a
battle field and as as the battle gets
more and more intense everything drops
out apart from the music that's the kind
of classic final mix decision where
everything might be added but actually
whilst you're watching the picture at
that point you think you know it might
be more powerful if we take everything
out and just play with the music so
that's that process is fantastic that's
the that's the process that gets the
hairs on the back of your neck raised my
work with production sound team probably
a lot of productions due to the nature
of the way their crude is probably not
close enough because I'm sometimes
booked quite late in the process so so
sometimes the projects being filmed
already TV work seems to be idling to
have a much better process because i
think i'm booked earlier and they go on
longer and then by the time we do the
second series you know the production
team if I know them and I'm brought to
learning often yes we try to everyone
tries to talk together it's more through
the supervising sound editor because the
Edison will be receiving the material
for the production sound crew but
certainly we try to start a dialogue
very early in the process
the process gets smoother on repeat jobs
repeat work because you you probably
understand where with the direct you on
the soul and the doctrine previous you
understand what their tastes are and you
start to form a bit of a common language
within within the Doublemint that I've
dubbed three films of Kenneth Branagh so
by the second one we then myself in the
entire sound crew understood that he was
absolutely syllable perfect on every
single word in the script every single
every single syllable when the script
had to be perfect and and represented on
the screen perfectly so you get to
understand how directors work and what
their intentions are so it does it does
get a lot easier there are difference in
delivery for film and TV in respects
whether we're delivering stereo or 5.1
surround sound cinema is 5.1 surround
sound where the speakers are in front of
you plus there's speakers around you
behind you and a sub speaker so that
gives you a much bigger scope for
delivery of sound and sound effects in
the in the rear and music spread around
all the different speakers TV UK TV
broadcasts tradition ease is still
delivered in stereo fit for BBC and ITV
so that doesn't limit some of the
creative freedom in terms of moving some
of the sounds around my biggest
challenge recently was on tinker tailor
the concept when they go into the pod
that's in the middle of the middle of
the circus which is meant to be a
soundproof room how to make it feel like
a soundproof room adding reverberation
to sound is quite an easy process you
could but taking reverberation off of a
sound and this was shot on the set but
it was shot very well on the set so it
was quite dead anyway but deadening it
down was an interesting very difficult
challenge actually we had about two or
three goes before we got it right and
that feeling of isolation as you go into
the room and you cut the world off and
it's a soundproof room
George take all of his knocks report by
Soviet High Command on their recent
naval exercises in the Black Sea just
what the Admiralty has been begging us
for some information on where did you
get this I didn't Percy and his little
cabal walk in with it look control up
the projects aren't probably most proud
of every few years you do you do a
project so it's obviously Tinker Tailor
is a fantastic project project to be
involved with because it was just so
much scope for interesting sound design
and in it the key scene in while the
latter reels actually relies entirely on
on the sound to tell the story which was
all added afterwards bar I think one
breath from gary oldman which was sink
as in recorded sound from the set
that scene is entirely made up from from
foley and sound effects and treated
sound effects and atmospheres and has
been entirely reconstructed and it
delivers one of the main plot points the
rip the revelation of the other of the
mole at the top of the circus and
recently the T in terms of TV work we'll
just finished the TV version of Sherlock
which was a fantastic show to work on
because it's such a massive scope for I
was a massive scope for sound especially
episode 2 which was hounded the
Baskervilles and in fact I got a friend
contact me recently said he watched any
realized actually you hardly ever saw
the hound and everything all of the
shocks and the feeling was delivered
through sound in most of the key scenes
involving the Hound early on in the show
it's only right towards the end that we
got CGI's in for the hound so for a show
like that sound is was absolutely
essential to create the atmospheres and
make up this kind of just half scene
hound flashing across the screen
receiving my first bath denomination
it's yeah it feels but it's very good
it's nice to get a pat on the back and
obviously recognition from from your
peers as always is always welcome and
it's nice to know that something you've
worked on has actually gone out and
people have enjoyed I think that's
that's nice and I've had a lot of
positive feedback over the last couple
of months from just from from various
sources and it's just it's nice to know
that that you've done something that
people watched and enjoyed
you